roger stone is the former trump uh
confidante aide
who has also been a guest on this
program roger stone of course
was convicted and then pardoned by
donald trump roger stone has a new
hypothesis which is that it is the
secret service that was somehow involved
in the trump riots on january 6th now i
have to admit we're going to look at a
clip of this
and if i'm totally honest with you i
don't fully understand the conspiracy
theory here and i kind of love it in the
sense that one of my favorite things is
a conspiracy theory that
doesn't even make any sense like it's
hard to even understand there's lots of
conspiracy theories where you hear it
and you say that just doesn't sound like
it's really the way things are
but this is one where i'm left asking
what exactly is roger stone even arguing
here so let's start taking a listen this
is roger stone on uh newsmax
i i'm not even sure what he's claiming
took place but it involves the secret
service let's take a listen i call it
fake news hey roger did you on january 6
did you go in the building
i would never even left the grounds of
the willard hotel yeah i came out in
front of the hotel in the morning for a
brief period to stretch my legs you can
watch the entire video a number of
patriots come up and ask for selfies or
patriots yeah patriots really want he's
popular with the patriot movement told
me that they're praying for me uh but no
i was not even on the capitol i do find
it odd that shortly after the
president's speech the secret service
contacted uh someone who worked for me
by phone and told me that uh they wanted
to escort me to the capitol
i declined uh i was not what do you
think that was about so i guess now what
stone is saying is
an unprovoked call from the secret
service saying we'd like to bring you to
the capitol would maybe be to to
implicate stone
maybe that's what they're saying that
they wanted to place stone there to then
implicate him in the riots even though
he didn't have anything to do with it
tell me if that's how you're
understanding this when you say that
it's it was there something about that
that sounded fishy
well i've worked for three american
presidents the secret service does not
do political chores the secret service
does not perform logistical tasks i find
it rather suspicious to be honest with
you it's suspicious in what way do you
believe even the hosts are sort of
unsure like what exactly are you you
alleging here uh that
perhaps um
insiders i'm trying to figure out how to
award this within the secret service or
the cia or other organizations were
involved nefariously
uh look i normally make that claim
because i don't know it but have but
understanding how the secret service
works obviously the implication is that
this is something the president wanted
i'm sorry i declined i was with uh
pastor mark burns and reverend randy
coggins right in my suite watching the
whole thing unfold on television
right so
my other question yeah making the k so i
guess the conspiracy theory is
the secret service so tucker carlson and
others have been saying it's the fbi
that was involved in the trump riots
roger stone is saying i believe i again
i'm he
we have to interpret it all because he's
being kind of cagey and weird about it
but he's saying the secret service which
would not normally be involved in
something like this tried to put me at
the scene of the crime
in order for me to later be implicated
or something like that now of course
we don't actually have proof that this
call even took place
if it did take place we don't have proof
that it was actually the secret service
there's no evidence for any of this but
it is another one of these um conspiracy
theories presented without any evidence
and we'll see if this one also becomes
part of the referential record remember
with tucker carlson tucker floated this
idea
that the fbi organized the trump riots
and then the next day congressman louis
gomer demanded we look into it even
though tucker presented it without any
evidence that's how they do it that's
how they insert narratives uh as fact
which then become referential in their
future claims we'll see if it happens
with this one but that's the latest
claim from roger stone the secret
service it sounds like everybody other
than actual trumpists was involved it
was the secret service it was the fbi it
was antifa dressed as trumpist but
definitely no trump is but at the same
time it was totally peaceful
um figure that one out